(soaring music)
- I know I'm not an
ordinary 10-year-old kid.
Then again,
no one's ordinary.
(upbeat music)
- Auggie can't change
the way he looks.
So maybe we can change
the way we see.
(bird wings fluttering)
- Tell me about
this new school of yours.
- Right now,
I'm just trying to fit in.
It's kind of been my motto ever
since I left my old school.
- Julian, you did not
leave your old school.
You were expelled for
being cruel to another boy.
(uplifting music)
I'm sure your father
has told you stories
about when I was a young girl.
- He says you don't really
like to talk about it.
- I don't, but now I think,
for your sake, I must.
(otherworldly music)
- Excuse me.
- Oh God, what is he doing?
- I saw this on your desk.
- Thanks.
- You're welcome.
- I didn't even know his name,
(children laughing)
but we had in common
one crucial thing.
- These are really good,
for a Jew.
(dramatic music)
- We had both seen how much
hate people are capable of,
(music flourishes)
and how much courage it took,
to be kind.
- Find them!
- You need to come
with me right now.
I know a way out.
In dark times, small things
remind us of our humanity.
(film projector whirring)
How would you like to
visit New York tonight?
- Sure.
- [Julien] Open your eyes.
(soaring music)
- World of reality
has its limits.
The world of imagination
is boundless.
(soaring music)
You're the bravest person
I've ever met.
(bats shrieking)
- You forget many things
in life,
but you never forget kindness.
Like love,
it stays with you forever.
(music flourishes)